so you Jimmy is not to be them you're
going to do some absorption on the right
hand and with your Center but the left
hand is going to be an angle deviation
when that doesn't mean that my right
hand is now it's hard there's nothing
nothing got hit so the weapon is going
to come to my right and the left hand is
going to come to my left and that's what
gives him the opening for the skee-bowl
okay
don't take you camming get cold pounds
you're not going to make it then buy
weapons to the right and this is the
tactic that is important to know what do
you do when your weapon is too though to
the outside of you you move towards it
it moves towards you that is the fastest
way to create an angle deflection
it's one foot maneuver not to snotty te
tank on to shield on full head sew only
my front foot moves and it's commenced
with the weight shift look he might wait
is back here that was the Academy then I
to Bushido tank on let's go so usually
the Joe is caught up in serves okay so
if I start with beginning I put my hand
at the top my left n goes shoulder width
down so that my hands are hanging
straight down for my shoulders as to why
this is too narrow got that that's old
okay and that distance tends to be about
one third the whole way through you know
there's some variation do you cut your
job all you are there not custom made
but you're looking about one-third all
design but more importantly the third
that's closest to you or let's just say
the shoulder width is closest to you
that is where you're going to determine
where can I hold one handed and still
have decent control over the joke so
where my left hand is now that is
generally the vicinity where I'm going
to operate the Joe one-handed so if we
go back you see
the same thing here I put it right where
I'm going to have power for it this
isn't going to be it this is going to be
in and so where is that hand well it's
at one-third shoulder with that not that
okay let's go back to this technique now
it's the same thing mold when I come
down here if I'm down here at this at
the end you're not going to have much
power on so find out one third when I
first shoulder width that's a little shy
I'd walk I wanted a little shorter baby
but the target is also going to
determine where i could be okay so let's
say i shorten it and look okay so i go
back to where i was and look so you're
in there just know that when you're 24
and you're not going to have that angle
deflection integrity that you want okay
but you can add to it and that's
important with the second right so let's
switch roles
so why does that happen you did have the
backup mass on the angle of deflection
and you have to understand that this key
is not a straight angle there's a cork
screwing to it okay let's be aware not
all those eyes okay just like when you
do Kochi dog in the back hand throws the
front side of the body boom you don't
have the backyard dead and you go like
that the body has a two-by-four on the
shoulders and on the hips connected with
the spine and it moves around
so the same thing with the joke
especially when you're one hand it's not
a cosmetic post it's a body
organizations oh this part is going to
throw it get your block up let's go just
like every kesa it should be in the body
it's not in your wrist that's the worst
okay and it's not in your eyes that's
bad it's in your body so your body is
moving boom your arms are just like a
ball and chain do you understand so you
get the chain is your arms and the ball
is at the end and you get the chain
movie not with your wrist not with your
arms do you see the difference okay that
is even more important which you've
actually taken away one of those other
power sources you don't have the other
left handed you go at the left arm so
you really have to use your body in this
movement coming around and you're
winding up don't do it like this your
body does it boom this hand pushes it
can't try it hey so if i drop my lead
shoulder then i'm basically falling
because i have part of my mouth outside
the base of my support and if I just
wait here without any adjustment you're
going to follow that way so that would
be that your mass is going in the
opposite direction of the strike so you
don't have a lot of huge it
pack that's why your strength is so weak
so you're going to be here and you're
dropping your shoulder like that you're
falling away from the target same thing
happens if your angle of attack is not
on the proper vector when you swing this
foot all the way around okay what's
happening you're falling have a body
alignment that keeps everything boom and
you could just be here all day nothing's
going to fall you're not doing any
adjustment at all so watch when you dip
the shoulder and watch when you over
rudder what I call run during okay your
back foot is supposed to be the power
foot so it's got a hit oh you can't have
it move it let's go